bonjour à tous c'est l'heure de
Parlement Hebdo 45 minutes pour faire le
tour de l'actualité politique et
parlementaire avec Mario Lefebvre
cette semaine un aveu en forme d'échec
François Hollande reconnaît que la
version de la commune du chômage n'est
pas au rendez-vous tous les espoirs
réside désormais dans le pacte de
responsabilité les syndicats ont déjà
filé à Matignon toute la semaine
l'Assemblée nationale a levé le voile
sur les détails de la tribution de la
réserve parlementaire elle c'est
l'enveloppe qui est distribue au député
pour le financement de projets locaux un
acte de transparence et une première le
détailler disponible sur le site
Internet de l'Assemblée nationale enfin
le plus de l'hebdo vous emmène au cinéma
la découverte d'un documentaire au bord
du monde close dragsel donne la parole à
ce que l'on entend jamais les sans-abris
bonjour vous êtes sénatrice de Paris
alors vous avez été ministre du Logement
sous pierre peyrégovoy et puis
secrétaire d'État toujours au logement
sous Lionel Jospin vous représentez
l'aile gauche du parti alors nous avons
demandé cette semaine à Olivier Faure de
votre prénom
a parfois la langue trop pendue et c'est
pas forcément utile le tirer votre
propre camp en même temps je lui
reconnais
des convictions une force de conviction
aussi capacité à entraîner sur cette
projet je préférais qu'elle utilise
parfois au service de tous et non pas
à semer la confusion et à donner le
sentiment qui puisse avoir nos propres
rangs des gens qui auraient trahi un
esprit qui nous serait commun parce que
ça c'est pas vrai alors Marie-Noëlle
liemann est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment de parfois tirer contre votre
propre corps comme le dieu Olivier Faure
écouter c'est simple quasiment depuis
que je suis militante on me dit cela
en fait il y a des camarades qui ont
toujours envie qui est une espèce de
monolitisme tout irait bien on serait
tous unis il y aurait pas de différence
quand il se trouve que j'ai un long
parcours et que j'ai fait partie du
Congrès d'épinets et François Mitterrand
et ceux qui ont fait la rénovation du PS
ont mis comme principe le fait qu'il
fallait
la diversité de la pensée des
convictions sociales et si on se
transforme dans un parti monolithique ou
alors les seuls légitimités sont les
désaccords de d'ambition personnelle
parce qu'elle leur soutenir les
présidentielles c'est toujours légitime
c'est de l'amitié mais avoir des
différences idéologiques voire politique
à certains moments là ce serait
l'affaiblissement je crois tout le
contraire est-ce que vous sentez isolé
ou au contraire est-ce que vous êtes
leader de ceux qui pensent tout bas ah
bah écoutez je suis pas du tout isolé je
suis pas isolée d'abord parce qu'il y a
des congrès et que nous avons fait
15-20% au Congrès presque la cinquième
des socialistes dans un climat où on
venait des tribus donc tout le monde
disait faux donner ses chances au
président etc deuxièmement quand on a
des votes comme sur l'Europe on fait une
convention du PS sur l'Europe refus du
traité transatlantique obligation de
renégocier le pack de stabilité nous
sommes majoritaires dans nos amendements
et puis il y a la société le peuple de
gauche le peuple les électeurs
socialistes quand vous voyez deux grands
syndicats comme la CGT il faut
s'ouvrière qui ont appelé à voter la CGT
mais le gros des militants de Force
Ouvrière a voté François Hollande ils
sont d'accord avec nous contre le cice
le Crédit Impôt compétition
est-il déchiré non il est divisé il
n'est pas déchiré on va en parler tout
au long évidemment de l'actualité de la
semaine on va commencer évidemment par
cet aveu en forme d'échec
ce lundi est marqué par un chiffre 0,3%
c'est le taux de chômage à ce dans cette
fin de 2013 le chef de l'État n'a donc
pas réussi à tenir sa promesse il était
en visite à Istanbul et François
Hollande connu son échec écouter
chômage a
augmenté à 2012 d'un million
un million et il a continué à augmenter
encore en 2013
plus de 170 000 c'est beaucoup la fin de
l'année une stabilisation
mais nous n'avons pas réussi dans
l'année 2013 à faire diminuer le chômage
en diminuer le rythme d'augmentation oui
en stabilisé
le niveau oui en cette fin d'année mais
pas le faire diminuer nous y avions mis
les moyens nécessaires et nous
continuerons à les mettre en termes
d'emploi aidés de contrats pour les
jeunes contrat de générations emploi
d'avenir formation mais nous ne pouvons
faire diminuer le chômage nous pourrons
le faire baisser dans les prochains mois
que si il y a de la croissance la
croissance commence obtient-elle elle
s'obtient avec le maintien d'une demande
intérieure de consommation mais surtout
d'investissement nous avons besoin
d'investissement Marie-Noël Linde c'est
bien de reconnaître son échec mais
quelque part ça fait un peu aveu
d'impuissance en nous quotidien on a
tout essayé contre le chômage d'abord
moi personnellement je pense que c'est
d'échec était prévisible et on peut pas
nous reprocher de ne pas le voir dit
puisque inverser la courbe du chômage en
Inde c'est que si on voulait atteindre
cet objectif aller faire une autre
politique dès le mois de février
le courant que je représente la gauche
du PS nous avons mis sur la table un
pacte de relance nous avions analysé que
premièrement la France peut pas attendre
la croissance qui lui tombe du ciel venu
de l'extérieur or c'est quand même ça
avec la théorie des cycles je ne sais
quoi non en politique on construit
l'avenir de son pays on tient compte des
conjonctures et des difficultés mais on
la construit volontarisme or depuis le
début le fameux Crédit Impôt
compétitivité emploi avec 20 milliards
qui va falloir financer l'absence de
revalorisation du SMIC vous avez repéré
que il va y avoir une votation en Suisse
pour revaloriser le SMIC à 4000 francs
suisses que l'Allemagne installe le SMIC
Barack Obama dans son discours dit qu'il
faut revaloriser le SMIC et que la
gauche française vient au pouvoir et de
ne même pas un coup de pouce au pouvoir
d'achat des couches populaires ce qui
d'ailleurs économiquement plombe notre
croissance donc nous avons fait des
propositions avec aussi des
investissements publics diminuer
drastiquement à marche forcée la dépense
publique pour atteindre les fibres
européens et anti croissance anti-emploi
et finalement même les contrats aidés
n'ont pas aidé à inverser cette courbe
du chômage ils sont là il faut il faut
rendre à César ce qui est à César l'idée
des contrats est une très bonne idée
elle doit contribuer à réduire le
chômage mais en revanche et nous
l'avions déjà dit pourquoi n'atteint pas
le chiffre parce que quand d'un côté
vous baissez les dotations collectivités
locales quand vous prétendez qu'elle
pourrait faire parce qu'elle gérait mal
beaucoup mieux avec moins mais faut pas
vous étonner que quand elles doivent
être au rendez-vous de la
complémentarité puisque l'État ne paye
pas tout et ben elles ne peuvent pas en
faire beaucoup les associations on
baisse leur subventions ou en les
augmentent pas elles peuvent pas faire
beaucoup de contrats aidés donc c'était
un peu hélas à craindre que cette baisse
de la dépense des collectivités
induisent un faible nombre de contrées
par rapport à nos ambitions alors
justement Marie-Noëlle Lienemann
il consiste à diminuer les charges qui
pèsent sur le coût du travail alors pour
ça il y a des contreparties qui sont
nécessaires puisqu'il y aura un effort
d'un côté de l'État un effort notamment
financier et les contreparties en
matière d'emploi en matière de formation
en alternance en matière de qualité de
l'emploi en matière d'instainissement en
France pas encore de chiffres précis le
gouvernement préfère miser sur des
engagements par thème emploie des jeunes
ou des seniors par exemple mais à la
sortie des entretiens les syndicats
avaient bien du mal à se mettre d'accord
le patronat exige désormais 60 milliards
d'allègements de charges mais toujours
sans contrepartie chiffrée nous avons
dit l'Observatoire des contreparties
nous préférerions l'appeler Comiti de
suivi du pacte c'est un projet ce pacte
c'est pas c'est un projet collectif
c'est un projet sur lequel nous
souhaitons avancer et bien entendons pas
je dirais des mesures 13 boutons pour
créer de l'emploi demain matin ce sera
une conséquence de la confiance
restaurée syndicat de salariés eux
refusent de signer un chèque en la balle
elle est dans le camp du patronat et si
le patronat ne comprend pas que pour
aider les entreprises il faut aussi que
celle-ci s'engagent à des embauches ou à
des évolutions de carrière pour les
salariés et bien nous aurons une impasse
les entretiens avec les partenaires
sociaux se poursuivent jusqu'à jeudi
Jean-Marc héro dévoilera alors sa
feuille de route pour mettre en place un
pacte qui s'annonce compliqué
vous croyez au contreparties de ce pacte
en termes d'emploi non je vais vous dire
pourquoi
d'abord premièrement par les faits vous
dit qu'il y a eu un changement de
politique mais enfin on est le crédit
pour compétitivité emploi 20 milliards
alors il y a un techniquement voilà et
maintenant on va passer à 35 30 35 c'est
15 de plus mais alors il y a l'actualité
nous dit tout de suite
vous avez du crédit un peu compétitivité
emploi le groupe Auchan qui va toucher
en deux ans 120 millions d'euros de
l'État qu'on va financer par la TVA et à
partir de là il annonce aujourd'hui et
enfin il y a quelques jours qui va
supprimer 300 emplois en France et on
peut pas dire couchant par ailleurs un
groupe en compétitivité mondiale pour
l'exportation de la France ça veut dire
que le
résultat de ma démonstration c'est que
c'est pas en donnant des cadeaux aux
entreprises sans avoir des objectifs
chiffrés mesurables et en disant si vous
n'attendez pas vos objectifs vous allez
vous devez rembourser alors est-ce qu'on
peut faire ça on pourrait le faire avec
des crédits de
on dit voilà il y a un crédit d'impôt
accorde de branche comme on l'a fait
pour les 35 heures si vous n'avez pas
atteint l'objet et on décline par
entreprise si vous n'avez pas atteint un
module où on sanctionne vous remboursez
mais là pour le coup ce qui est ça ne
peut pas être de la création d'emploi ou
une partie du cas déjà c'est qu'on
licencie ce qui touche deuxièmement
c'est de négocier des salaires ou de la
lutte contre la précarité car ça durera
aussi de l'activité économique
parce que c'est démocratie c'est un
pacte entre le Parti social-démocrate et
du syndicats
pas du tout il est né au libéral je le
dis tout net pour une raison simple
c'est que la sociale démocratie c'est un
accord entre les syndicats et le Parti
de Gauche pour créer un rapport de force
et permettre à compromis social avec le
Medef c'est pas l'inverse c'est pour ça
que Peter Hart qui est un ancien
conseiller de garde bien souvent les
livres
beaucoup de socio-démocrates qu'on teste
le fait que la politique de shreder a
été social-démocrate il qualifie
eux-mêmes de néolibéral le congrès du
SPD et notamment mes amis de la gauche
du SPD car nous ne sommes pas isolés ils
font presque un quart du SPD et par
ailleurs Peter Hartz vous retient le
discours qu'on a entendu truc il vaut
mieux travailler de payer exploiter à
mort c'est pas grave vous travaillez
vous êtes un homme tandis que si vous
avez par malheur vous êtes indemnisé et
que vous gagnez plus alors là vous êtes
un assisté notre débat sur l'économie
avec un livre choc un livre sur la
France et l'état de la France en 2040
c'est notre zone de la semaine
bonjour Nicolas bavrez bonjour vous avez
l'auteur de ce livre lettre béninoise
sortie chalevin Michel si je résume un
petit peu cet ouvrage c'est l'état de la
France en 2040 et alors et on regarde
bien l'état de la France en 2040 c'est
une catastrophe on a plus de trésorerie
la France est en faillite on est au bord
de la société on est plus notre siège à
l'ONU c'est ce qui nous attend c'est ce
qui nous attend si nous ne changeons pas
de manière très importante effectivement
notre modèle politique économique et
social donc ce livre a été écrit comme
un conte politique et moral précisément
pour éviter que ce qui est indiqué là
ce produit mais je n'ai rien inventé je
n'ai fait que prolonger ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui et qui est la désintégration
de l'appareil productif de la société
sur la natation française
ce Navis sur l'échec c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui il est clair que on a un
échec la stratégie mise en oeuvre en
2012 sur la croissance sur le chômage et
puis sur les déficits et la dette donc
il est clair que il faut changer le
pacte il essaye de comme on l'a dit de
changer en donnant plus de la prime à
l'offre à la production à l'entreprise
en créant de l'emploi plutôt dans le
secteur privé dans le secteur public et
en baissant la dépense publique donc
dans ces principes je le trouve bon en
revanche j'ai d'énormes doutes sur sa
réalisation parce que premièrement on
voit déjà beaucoup de zigzags puisqu'on
explique que par exemple en matière de
dépenses publiques on va toucher niveau
département ni au fonctionnaires ni à
l'éducation donc on se demande d'où ça
va venir en fait sur le constat c'est
que ça ne peut pas marcher en fait moi
je pense que c'est à l'état de point
d'interrogation
là où je rejoins Marie-Noëlle linnane
également c'est que quand on regarde les
forces économiques et sociales qui
soutiennent dans la société c'est quand
même une configuration assez volatile et
instable on a un président de la
République de gauche et le patronat qui
est la seule force qui soutient on n'a
pas pour l'instant de mesure claire et
de financement qui soit bien et ensuite
on peut se demander si le gouvernement
qui a mis en place la précédente
stratégie qui a donc échoué et capable
de d'opérer et d'être le gouvernement de
ce tournant selon vous Nicolas baverest
de se réformer bien sûr c'est difficile
quand même quand on lit en plus
difficile
fort heureusement les démocraties sont
des conservateurs c'est pas facile de
réformer l'Allemagne c'est pas facile de
réformer aucun de ces aucun de ces pays
mais c'est possible et d'ailleurs quand
on regarde ce qui s'est passé dans des
pays très différents comme le Canada la
Suède l'Allemagne ou en fait le
privilège des pays développés c'est
comme il y a beaucoup de capital
accumulés beaucoup de savoir-faire vous
pouvez retourner à un grand pays
développé en deux ans et avoir des
résultats très solides en 5 ans mais
maintenant c'est pour ça qu'il est sans
attendre 2040 il faut vraiment s'y
mettre parce qu'on est on est la limite
vraiment on est sur le propre très
proche marine justement ça sert
d'électrochoc ce genre de
régulièrement tire la sonnette d'alarme
et
souhaite un cap qui qui est cohérent
dans sa pensée moi je pense qu'il faut
un sursaut mais je pense qu'il faut
qu'il soit le point d'appui de se
sursaut est différent il est alternatif
je pense que la thématique le changement
c'est maintenant était juste il fallait
changer la France maintenant maintenant
moi je ne pense pas ben non je pense je
pense on est trop dans la continuité du
passé pour ma part je pense qu'il y
avait des points majeurs qui sont
déterminants pour notre avenir je pense
qu'on doit tout mettre le paquet sur la
rue capacité la capacité à produire on
n'aura pas les mêmes stratégies moi je
pense qu'il faut des grands travaux des
grands investissements
je pense qu'il faut mettre le paquet sur
la redistribution fiscale et pas des
mesurer tout après on remet sans arrêt
de l'impôt moi je pense qu'il fallait
que les couches populaires voient
baisser leur impôts et je suis hostile à
la baisse de la TVA faut une CSG
progressive foudre une meilleure
distribution des efforts
en particulier sur le calcul des côtés
sont sociales il faut qu'on prenne un
choix stratégique moi mon choix il est
clair il est la croissance qualitative
durable soutenue par des investissements
publics et des contrats de développement
avec les branches industrielles les
productives de l'autre côté la
redistribution des riches 3emement des
nouveaux droits au travailleur et par
ailleurs un grand défaut de conviction
collective autour de nos valeurs
républicaines voilà sur votre ouvrage
j'ai lu pages 30 Hassan Bono qui est
donc le président du FMI un Béninois qui
vient à Paris pour essayer de sauver
finalement ce qui est encore sauvable en
France il veut sauver cette part
d'universel du pays c'est ça qui nous
manque en France c'est ça qui peut
s'éteindre je crois que les Français
aujourd'hui clairement non plus en
eux-mêmes ni dans leur pays et ça c'est
un problème qui est extrêmement
important en même temps la France elle
est encore porteuse de valeurs
universelle et puis la France elle a une
ressource incroyable quand on regarde
ces mêmes français à l'étranger la
France numérique vous voulez elle existe
le drame c'est qu'elle Francisco
aujourd'hui dans le Silicon Valley vous
avez 600 entreprises qui sont dirigées
par des Français vous avez 6000
ingénieurs français pourquoi est-ce
qu'on a fait un système qui les oblige à
aller là-bas pour faire ce genre de
choses et pas chez nous donc l'eau c'est
vraiment possible de changer et là où je
rejoins madame linmann sur un point
c'est sur la production cette semaine
vous avez eu 4 chiffres dramatiques
celui du chômage on en a parlé mais les
investissements directs étrangers moins
77 % un chiffre épouvantable et si tu
industriel on a détruit deux fois plus
de sites industriels qu'on en a créé et
les créations sont un plus bas
historique la recherche et le
développement qui est l'avenir on est
tous d'accord pour dire que c'est par
l'innovation dans un pays qui est un
pays
vieillissant et en mettant un pays qui
restera forte heureusement avec quoi
c'est haut c'est par l'innovation on a
détruit plus d'emplois dans la recherche
et développement qu'on en a créé donc là
si vous voulez c'est pas on dit que
c'est du déglise mais c'est pas vrai
tous les facteurs d'alerte on les a et
donc maintenant il faut bouger et on
n'est pas obligé de bouger droite contre
gauche quand je regardais en 45 on a
quand même été capable de faire un pacte
productif qui a permis de remettre de
reconstruire le pays aujourd'hui on est
dans la même situation il faut
reconstruire notre appareil de
production un lanceur d'alerte Nicolas
barres vous pouvez définir comme ça
passe non non parce que le les alertes
elles ont été lancées maintenant c'est
une injonction agir exactement et sans
attendre le constat est le même pour
tous les deux il faut réformer est-ce
qu'il faut pas aussi revoir un petit peu
cette parole politique est-ce que les
hommes politiques n'ont pas un devoir de
responsabilité alors je vous rejoins je
pense que la parole politique est très
abîmée et que là on en a eu un exemple
quand on a le chômage qui est vraiment
un cancer qui est en train de de
détruire l'économie mais aussi la
société et la démocratie on a le chômage
qui augmente de 5,7% dans une année on
explique que c'est une stabilisation et
bien dans une démocratie quand on
commence par la corruption du langage
c'est du totalitarisme mou alors
effectivement c'est pas l'Union
soviétique c'est molaçons mais quand les
mots jurent avec les choses ça on ne
peut plus d'ailleurs débattre parce
qu'il faut qu'il lui déplace dans une
démocratie mais si les mots ne veulent
plus rien dire et si c'est à la tête de
l'État qu'on valide cette corruption du
langage alors là c'est vrai que les
choses
pas politiques ne disent plus la vérité
sont peut-être pour vous
moi je ne supporte pas qu'on fasse blanc
et qu'on dise blanc et qu'on fasse noir
on n'avait pas écrit on a dit qu'on
était contre la TVA sociale que c'était
pas la question du coup du travail
après on peut découvrir ou d'un certain
temps mais déjà en place sa politique
après on peut la nuancer parce que le
réel 2 on doit pas nier le réel et faire
comme si les chiffres que donne monsieur
baverest sont justes ils sont alarmants
moi j'ai pas la même accord que lui sur
les investissements je pense que la
France historiquement eu du capital
public qui a été des contrats avec le
privé parce que il y a jamais eu non
plus économie administrée et tant qu'il
y aura pas de tout du capital public
réel donc autour de filières et des
projets nous serons hyper fragiles par
rapport au capitalisme étrangers
le titre de votre ouvrage lettre
béninoise chez Albin Michel merci
d'avoir participé à notre merci
alors le président de la République
était mis en cause à l'Assemblée c'était
mardi il a cet échange à suivre réaction
lors des questions au gouvernement le
député UMP Guillaume l'arrivée de la
République qu'il estime illégitime une
critique sévère qui a provoqué une
bronca sur les bancs de l'hémicycle je
vous propose de réécouter cette
intervention du thé de l'Yonne et la
réponse du Premier ministre et puis
bientôt 2 ans François Hollande est
installé à l'élite il a été élu par
défaut sur un seul programme
l'anti-sarkozyme il préside la France
comme il a libéré le Parti socialiste en
multipliant les petits arrangements et
les grands renoncements alors la vérité
même si elle vous déplaît même si elle
vous fait hurler c'est que le Président
de la République avait pris devant les
Français en engagement solennel que soit
engagement c'était de faire reculer le
massage cet engagement et cela vous gêne
il n'est pas tenu la vérité et que la
présidente Hollande naufrage
qu'attendez-vous pour vous en aller
attendez-vous qu'un communiqué du
président de la République déclare que
François Hollande a déclaré de rompre sa
vie commune avec vous est-ce que vous
soutenez ceux qui dimanche dernier oh
tenue les mêmes propos c'est la
démocratie qui décide que leur vote vous
plaisent ou non c'est le vote du peuple
français rien d'autre peut exister sinon
le respect du vote des citoyens
marie-noëlleman peut-on tout dire sur
les bancs du Parlement
oui en fait le spectacle c'est la
première fois qu'on s'attaque
première fois chaque fois que la gauche
est au pouvoir la droite considère que
le gouvernement illégitime Jacques
Chirac disait qu'en François Mitterrand
a été élu qui ferait pas qu'il ferait
pas 5 ans à l'époque c'était 7 ans le
nain donc vous voyez bien qu'ils serais
pas 5 ans donc il y a toujours eu un
prochain éligibilité quand la gauche
arrive au pouvoir et qui t'a dit la
tradition de la gauche française
notamment la droite française avec la
notamment que la Cinquième République
qui pense que naturellement elle est là
pour truc et la gauche c'est pas des
récits responsables ils sont pas
capables de gérer ils sont heureux bref
il y a toujours eu tropisme alors
certains ras-le-bol dans la société
depuis le début il y a des
mécontentement ceux qui est significatif
c'est notre faiblesse il faut pas se
raconter l'histoire ça ne justifie en
rien le procès légitimité ça ne justifie
en rien la radicalisation de la droite
qui flirte avec l'extrême droite ou des
thèses malsaines mais la réalité c'est
que pour tenir tête pour tenir bon pour
être capable de changer il faut être
fort et pour être fort il faut que la
gauche soit unie parce que quand on a
fait 50 et quelques pourcents mettant
51% et bien on peut pas se permettre de
ne pas fédérer le camp politique qui a
donné au pouvoir et le fait que François
Hollande ait refusé au début ou en tout
cas n'est pas fait les efforts au début
de son quinquennat pour fédérer la
gauche au motif qu'on avait la majorité
tout seul le PSL assemblée
je pense que c'est les signes de
l'erreur de début du quinquennat après
se rajoute l'histoire européenne dont on
sait que le peuple de gauche et le
peuple français attendez énormément de
cette survivre mais pas seulement pour
les élections européennes c'est le doute
sur le fait que on est sur le cap qu'on
avait annoncé donc moi je le dis à
François Hollande aujourd'hui exactement
aujourd'hui si François Hollande veut
pouvoir reprendre pied il faut qu'ils
n'ont pas fasse tourner en qui n'est pas
un tournant qui est la continuité de ce
qui a fait depuis le début il faut qu'il
fasse vraiment le changement de cap avec
un nouveau pacte majoritaire avec sa
majorité de gauche
sur lequel Jean-Marc Ayou a raison de
dire la droite surf sur tous les
ras-le-bols accumulés les thèses
au niveau du poujadisme à l'extrême
droite etc qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est
que quand à gauche n'est pas non plus
dans la rue pour faire obstacle aux
pensées
racistes comment on était capable en 34
de férer Dieu sait qu'à l'époque entre
Parti communiste qui était proche de
l'Union soviétique et puis Léon Blum il
y avait des montagnes ce qui n'est plus
le cas aujourd'hui on était capable de
faire l'amour oui la gauche de défendre
dans la rue mais pour qu'elle défende
dans la rue faut qu'elle ait quelque
chose à défendre il faut qu'il y ait à
défaut d'être d'accord sur tout qui est
quelques grandes réformes majeures
quelques avancées concrètes pour les
salariés et qu'on continue pas à prendre
des discours qui ressemblent à ceux du
Medef donc voilà il faut qu'on retrouve
cet élan collectif car sinon il va y
avoir une fragilisation collective non
seulement de la gauche mais de la
démocratie justement on va parler de de
ce thème également avec toujours dans
l'hémicycle à l'Assemblée nationale le
ministre de l'Éducation va s'en pays qui
a dû lui aussi répondre à cet appel au
boycott en français
rumeur pour lancer par des mouvements
extrémistes en Île-de-France contre ce
qu'ils appellent la théorie du genre je
vous propose d'écouter le ministre et
puis on en discute juste après jamais
nous ne renoncerons à l'enseignement de
l'égalité que nous inscrivons au fronton
de toutes nos écoles nous lutter et nous
continuerons de le faire contre toutes
les discriminations contre le racisme
contre les inégalités mais je veux très
solennellement rassurer tous les parents
de France n'écoutez pas ceux qui veulent
semer la division et la haine dans les
écoles ce que nous faisons ce n'est pas
la théorie du genre je la refuse c'est
promouvoir les valeurs de la République
et l'égalité entre les hommes et les
femmes théorie du genre on ne n’est pas
fille ou garçon et on le devient en
quelque sorte
donc c'est clair et je pense que on
n'est pas elle n'est pas inscrite à
l'école cette horreur donc ce que
j'allais dire cette rumeur
d'où viennent les rumeurs c'est pas le
sujet parce qu'au bout d'un moment quand
on dit d'où vient la rumeur on finit par
se poser la question de savoir s'ils ont
pas une certaine légitimité
c'est des coups ou politico idéologiques
d'un certain nombre de groupes qui eux
pour le coup vont sur valoriser l'idée
qui pourrait y avoir une menace la
théorie du genre pour combattre la
réalité du dessus de notre volonté de
d'assurer l'égalité maintenant je lui
dis tout net de ce point de vue je
trouve que la clarification de Vincent
payant est utile il n'y a pas au
gouvernement de soutien à la théorie du
genre c'est important que je sois
clairement compris par tous les Français
en tout cas il y avait du doute chez
certains qui n'étaient pas toujours des
gens avec lesquels nous n'avons pas de
convergence ou nous électeurs donc
peut-être qu'il y a eu de la confusion
et donc il est important de l'avoir
rappelé alors sur l'école je trouve que
c'est très important qu'évidemment de la
lutte contre la discrimination et
surtout contre les stéréotypes parce que
ce qui est vrai c'est que la société
envoie des stéréotypes mais c'est la
question de la méthode c'est la méthode
la grande question c'est celle de
l'égalité et la première égalité toutes
les égalités ne sont il y en a pas des
certaines supérieurs à d'autres l'échec
scolaires le petit gamin qui est dans
les catégories sociales qui ont du mal
c'était aussi important que les
inégalités hommes-femme et donc c'est le
combat de l'égalité est au cœur de
l'école publique et je trouve qu'il
devrait même mieux mettre en valeur ce
qui fait en Z avec les moyens
faites pas trop avec les questions de
société à moi de toute façon j'ai
toujours dit il faut jamais
pour les questions de société on en fait
passer sur les questions sociales ça
doit toujours parce que quand ça ne doit
pas servir de par avant à l'absence de
réforme sociale et d'amélioration des
questions sociales des gens ça n'est pas
un chiffon rouge c'est nécessaire à
l'émancipation collective l'émancipation
sociale l'émancipation dans les mœurs
alors mercredi les députés ont dû jouer
la transparence
la réserve parlementaire a été rendue
publique plus de 80 millions d'euros
désormais chacun peut voir comment sont
répartis les 130 000 euros par député
grâce à cette transparence certains
favoritismes sont apparus mais ils ne
sont pas toujours bien assumer et
Jean-Baptiste Daoulas
en 2013 les députés ont distribué
81,6 millions d'euros grâce à leur
réserve parlementaires la liste des
subventions est longue pas moins de 246
pages c'est la première année qu'elle
est rendue publique sur le site de
l'Assemblée nationale la réserve
parlementaire sort en fin de l'ombre
c'est extrêmement encadré et ce n'est
pas le député
qui fait la
à toutes sortes d'associations en
Seine-Saint-Denis et vous verrez la
réponse dans le viseur de JK Perez les
subventions décidé par Claude bartholon
dans son département la transparence
n'empêche pas quelques crochets entre
députés
financent des associations comme l'uni
Lunel ces syndicats étudiants il y a une
polémique qui est née est-ce que vous
vous trouvez ça normal de financer ces
syndicats étudiants avec la réserve
parlementaire moi par exemple je trouve
normal de financer du nef pourquoi pas
puisqu'on subventionne des associations
à vrai dire je vais vous dire ma pensée
c'est que je pense que tout ça n'a plus
de sens
je personnellement je ne suis pas
favorable à la réserve parlementaire
pendant 5 ans ou 6 ans je sais plus 5
ans puisque je suis devenu ministre
entre je n'ai jamais utilisé
parlementaire je sais même pas qu'il
existait donc en tant que sénatrice je
n'ai pas utilisé la totalité de mission
j'ai d'ailleurs laissé à mes collègues
d'ailleurs vous allez récupérer simple
j'ai aidé l'association Habitat et
humanisme qui à Nantes a fait un foyer
pour les personnes en difficulté et qui
avait besoin de financement le
financement global était pas bouclé pour
le mobilier j'ai par ailleurs soutenu
une association qui faisait la promotion
de Jean Jaurès et qui a fait un grand
spectacle sur Jean Jaurès à corde et qui
diffuse d'un truc la France donc moi il
y a aucun souci et alors je sais pas le
total doit faire 120000 euros à peu près
tous les détails sont publiés de toute
façon
on dit pourquoi le nom de l'association
bah il y a des tas d'associations qui
ont des qui ont des noms un peu tout et
qui font du travail ensemble et puis ce
qui est ennuyeux dans cette affaire
c'est que toutes celles qui n'avez vous
avez dit non dit pourquoi pas moi voilà
donc tout ça me paraît
la vraie question c'est que les modes de
financement public aujourd'hui ne
permettent pas toujours aux associations
de fonctionner correctement alors cette
semaine hasard du calendrier les
départements doivent également remettre
leur déclaration d'intérêts ce que vous
avez rempli la vôtre bien sûr
heureusement puisque c'est le premier
février qu'on devait l'avoir envoyé donc
on a une déclaration d'intérêt une
déclaration de patrimoine c'est hyper
compliqué alors je pense que c'est
compliqué parce que on a
modifié le système maintenant qu'on le
connaît par exemple on vous demande
depuis le début de votre mandat
qu'est-ce que vous avez gagné etc
non moi ça me gêne pas à partir du
moment on le sait c'est moins difficile
d'aller reconstituer parce que au moins
chaque année on fait le point et puis on
n'est pas obligé d'aller chercher ça va
suffire à moraliser la vie politique
cette transparence non non
vous savez la chasse de contre la
turpitude
et sans fin moi je suis plutôt pour la
transparence
je suis par exemple j'ai été pendant
longtemps alors que j'étais en cotonie
mon camarade fort me disait que j'avais
j'étais au courant j'ai dénoncé la
corruption pS je me suis fait insulter
mon parti j'ai pris position que c'est
des ministres j'étais la seule à dire
pas de financement privé pour les
campagnes François Mitterrand gentiment
mais qui pouvait pas le faire etc donc
moi je dis sur cette affaire
pour le coup c'est le côté que je trouve
plutôt bien dans les dans le revenu Nord
mais il vous a pas échappé que même dans
la vertueux Allemagne protestante il y a
énormément de corruption aussi donc ce
qui est le plus important c'est la
transparence le droit des citoyens à
pouvoir dénoncer la liberté de la presse
et surtout que la politique redevienne à
débat sur les idées et les actes et non
pas sur le pistage des comportements
individuels des gens on va passer à
notre sujet marinel linman on va passer
au jeudi avec une journée consacrée au
logement
il y a eu la remise du rapport de l'abbé
Pierre sur le mal logement et un texte
débattu au Sénat qui s'est penché pour
la deuxième fois sur le texte allure
c'est le projet de loi pour une
meilleure accès au logement au programme
la garantie universelle des loyers et
l'encadrement des loyers il a été adopté
il y a quelques jours à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est votre sujet parce que
vous avez été secrétaire au logement si
vous aviez été en charge aujourd'hui si
vous avez été ministre vous seriez fait
quoi dans ce projet de loi
de toute façon je trouve qu'il y a
peut-être parfait je sais pas
c'est compliqué le logement parce que le
projet de loi lui-même c'est le
l'encadrement du logement en disant et
de l'autre côté il y a tout le débat
budgétaire sur les moyens donnés d'abord
un bon point au gouvernement cette année
on réaugmente le nombre de logements
sociaux HLM construit et il faut
poursuivre et je crois que les mesures
qui ont été prises par le gouvernement
le président de la République
et Madame Duflot nous à penser qu'on va
remonter le truc arrivera-t-on au 500
000 logements là il y a sans doute des
choses complémentaires à faire et en
particulier en Île-de-France mais j'ai
vu madame Duclos proposait qu'on libère
du foncier supplémentaire alors
il y a une très bonne idée c'est la
garantie universelle des loyers alors
certaines associations estiment que le
texte est évidé de sa substance est
modifications
ce sujet aussi Sénat qu'est-ce qui va se
passer toutes les propriétaires vont
pouvoir aller locataires vont pouvoir
faire appel à une garantie publique qui
ne coûtera rien aux propriétaires et au
locataire qui va donner un socle de
garantie notamment le remboursement le
versement direct au propriétaire en cas
d'un pays de loyer de 18 mois
correspondant au loyer médian du coin
c'est-à-dire tous les gens qui ont des
super loyers ne toucheront le niveau des
du loyer médian déclenchement tout de
suite du suivi social quand il s'agit
personnes en difficulté il y a des tas
de droits auxquels les gens ne savent
même pas qu'ils ont droit troisièmement
la possibilité quand même évidemment le
Trésor public va recouvrer et en
particulier si jamais il y a des
locataires de mauvaise foi qui ne paient
pas leur logement alors quelle est la
différence entre pourquoi les
associations se disent on l'a vidé de la
substance elle demandait le
cautionnement
constitutionnel sur la capacité
d'interdire la caution aimer je le dis
tout net quel est le propriétaire qui va
être assez stupide pour refuser une
garantie gratuite de toucher pendant 18
mois des impayés alors qui on sait
qu'aujourd'hui en France 60% des
cautions ne peuvent pas être appelés
pour des tas de problèmes juridiques et
qu'il faut faire plein de procédures
juridiques alors que là ça va se
déclencher vite tout de suite quand les
impayés arriveront la gueule gagnera
contre la caution et si par Marie il y
avait encore des gens qui discriminent
par la caution on aura là légitimité
constitutionnelle
sur le mal de logement évidemment
exactement il y a un appel lancé demain
par la Fondation
comme le premier appel de l'abbé Pierre
il y a 60 ans à l'époque il avait permis
de 400 millions de francs vous pensez
que je sais pas si c'est
un appel financier moi j'irai cet appel
et s'il fallait donner bien sûr je donne
tous les gens tous les ans il y a des
tas de gens qui donnent la fondation de
l'abbé Pierre alors cette semaine
justement le plus de l'hebdo revient sur
la situation des sans domicile fixe à
Paris
au bord du monde c'est le titre d'un
documentaire de Klaus Bruxelles diffusé
au cinéma depuis la semaine dernière le
Cinéas est allé à la rencontre de
sans-abris la nuit à Paris pendant un an
il leur donne la parole et face à la
caméra c'est sans abri évoque leur
souffrance mais aussi leur espoir Agathe
picastin
Michel Jenny Pascal Christine et les
autres ils sont les héros ordinaires
choisis par le réalisateur Klaus drxel
qui signe son premier documentaire au
cinéma la misère témoigne à visage
découvert une misère qui dérange dans
l'une des plus belles villes du monde
Paris il y a des matins je me lève et
j'en ai vraiment marre à fond à chaque
fois qu'il y a le Marathon de Paris
secours moi je cours le Marathon de
Paris
au bord du monde lève le voile sur la
pauvreté dans nos rues celles que l'on
ignore celle pour qui on ne sont pas le
plus cherché de réponse
c'est comme si on considère pas ce que
tu es là tout est fini pour toi c'est
même plus la peine de s'arrêter c'est
même plus la peine d'écouter
la non-réponse au problème qui nous
maintient ainsi
c'est ça le pire Klaus Drexel habitué à
la fiction pose un regard tendre très
cinéma sur une réalité poignante selon
un récent sondage de l'Insee le nombre
de cent domicile en France a augmenté de
50% en à peine plus de 10 ans
alors quand vous entendez Christine
cette sans domicile fixe dire la
non-réponse au problème qui nous
maintient ici c'est ça le pire qu'est-ce
que vous lui répondez est-ce qu'il y a
suffisamment de réponses aujourd'hui je
voudrais dire que la première des choses
c'est de ne pas être ne pas rendre ses
invités pour nous-mêmes individuellement
et pour la société collectivement c'est
injuste de dire qu'il y a pas de réponse
on multiplie des places des bernement
etc et en même temps on a une
dégradation sociale et et des
conséquences humaines dramatiques et ça
nous ramène au début du sujet ces
personnes ont eu des fragilités des
difficultés qui ont en laissant brisé
alors le vrai problème c'est que d'abord
la crise du logement n'est pas
simplement celle des SDF il faudrait pas
opposer d'important faut pas opposer les
SDF aux catégories modestes qui
n'arrivent pas non plus et qui n'en sont
pas encore heureusement dans un
basculement cette nature deuxièmement
les problèmes ne sont pas que de
logement ils sont aussi des problèmes
d'accompagnement humain de nos
structures
exactement et troisièmement je pense que
dans le cas de Paris il est fondamental
que la métropole en face sa première
priorité parce que vous ne pourrez pas
régler tous les problèmes de logement
d'hébergement de suivi des personnes
soit une grande solidarité territoriale
donc moi je pense que
pour ouvrir des centres en plus si vous
voulez que les moyens d'hébergement
soient répartis sur l'ensemble du
territoire il faut quand même que on va
pas mettre à Paris multiplier du
logement du logement même si Madame
Hidalgo a bien raison donc d'avoir un
engagement précis et que Bertrand
delanouille avait tenu les siens donc en
tout cas sur cette question là moi
j'appelle les Français au moment des
municipales de 82 se saisir de sujet
parce que vous vous montrez un reportage
qui nous amène à l'humanité mais moi
j'ai participé à plusieurs débats où on
voyait des reportages vous avez des gens
aisés qui refusent de mettre des HLM en
face de chez eux en vous disant moi j'ai
vu les bidonvilles de nairobie je veux
pas avoir ces gens-là qui viennent payer
chez moi donc pour que la société
française
fasse de cette cause une grande un des
grands débats des municipales
absolument merci beaucoup marine d'avoir
participé à notre émission voyons
surtout la semaine prochaine à la
semaine prochaine bonne semaine
que s'est-il passé il y a 18 ans dans
les montagnes de Tibérine qui a tué les
moines trappistes